Hello. Nice to see you again.
Sorry it's been a little while.
I am currently hiking in Algonquin Park in Ontario, Canada.
This particular hike is called Booth's Rock Trail.
It's a pretty lovely one. It's very pretty.
Lots of history around here.
Lots of mud and mosquitos, just what you'd expect from the Canadian wilderness.
However, please do not be fooled into thinking this video is more exciting than it actually is.
I'm just here to tell you what I'm going to do at VidCon this year.
But if you can make it through, then I promise you'll get a nice view of Canada at the end,
so there's your incentive.
So the first thing is my new short film,
which I'm hoping will be finished in time to screen at VidCon,
and we're already at the view. So that's good.
This isn't the main view?
EMILY: No.
CHARLIE: Okay, so I can just not show it to them. Good.
CHARLIE: It looks like a beautiful painting.
And you're missing out. Sorry.
So yeah, if you would like to see my new short film
"Strangers in a Bed" in its hopefully finished form,
I think we'll be screening that on Saturday.
We are actually here at the view now, aren't we?
You go enjoy it, I'll update them,
and then I'll come join you.
Emily and I have also organized our own panel this year called INTERMIX.
The basic concept is that we wanted to try and bring together filmmakers
from a more traditional background who are releasing their films online
and filmmakers like myself who started doing stuff online
and now are getting into filmmaking.
So that's going to be a screening of lots of short films online
and then I'm going to bring out some of the filmmakers,
have a chat with then.
So, hopefully that will be entertaining for you as well
if you would like to come along to that.
That is also on the Saturday, again not sure what time.
And then as per normal, I'm also going to try and meet as many people
who want to meet me as I possibly can,
so on Thursday and Friday, I'm doing a mix of taking pictures with people
and signing things for people
Can't remember which one's on which day.
Again, just very, very good at this whole update thing.
I'm on a couple of panels as well that I haven't organized
which are also filmmakey related.
Can't remember what those are called at all, so that's useful.
Tell you what I'll do is I'll write a blog post with correct information in it
so you can look at that.
I'll put it in the description.
And that's it. My arm hurts now.
I want to go look at the view, so hopefully I will see you at VidCon.
Okay. Here is the view.
Good Lord, that's pretty.
Holy...
Holy hell.
Holy mackerel.
Do you like it?
CHARLIE: Yeah. Let's have lunch. The end.
STEPHEN FRY VOICE: You've just had the almost imponderable joy of watching charlieissocoollike,
which makes you, like, cool.
CHARLIE: Okay, I shouldn't try and film this bit.  Oh, God.
CHARLIE: Good start, good start.
Alright, that's closed enough. EMILY: You did it!